okay so gambit you throw stuff yeah you
fill it with energy and then you throw
it hard harder than you can you throw a
business card or you know I could do the
black card you know with the pickup for
and you choose any color and no no deck
I've played you know yes also you know
no mark what if you run out of cards I
can throw other things you know I got
some change left in my pockets because I
had a euro earlier at Giro what do you
say yeah I say yarrow okay well Nolan I
say yo hahaha
I say yarrow I knew I knew we were
arrested even what's the French word for
yarrow you're wrong
Captain Picard of the USS Enterprise is
cutted jean-luc Picard of the USS
Enterprise
okay are you hearing as we're speaking
how incredibly lame you are someone was
hungry I'm across the room like Chuck us
an edge in his mouth that's cool would
you not like to be in a lunchroom and
you say to me a gun dad sandwich me and
I thought you are in a mouth you can
throw a gyro bow don't look at you no
it's okay you can yeah yeah you can
throw a yarrow but you will get it I'm
gonna show everyone yah turn a yarrow
before but ah here we go this is that
the one you are you're garbage that's
such a brutal thing to say to another
person
nice face warmer - oh give me a sock and
just cut out the face but this is custom
it's custom it looks like you're framing
the worst part of you my face hahahahaha
eat a dick ha ha yeah just look at each
other for a while huh make it better
make it better than make it intimate I'm
sorry I'm sorry you're doing great
you're thinking the IRL are you